last time I saw you I think was at the
airport at the airport so yeah yeah I
remember bumping into you at the airport
i well i sought you out by the way you
were the most recognizable person in the
world oh it's a real world yes like
stand out you know it's so it's funny
because I've had my kids in my family
say wear glasses wear dark glasses and I
do on Sesame Street wore glasses and
walk down the street people see this
freak and they're like hey it's Conan
where the lady's hat yeah so I was going
to New York to get out for season one of
my show to get a webby award
webby award yeah and so for the webby
awards you have to give a five word
speech so I'm nervous I have no idea
what I'm gonna say well I have one idea
which it was bad and I saw you and I was
thinking like do I have the balls to go
up to Conan and asked him to write my
speech for me and I did so I went up to
you it asked me write my speech I think
you maybe didn't believe me or take it
seriously so I came up to you drink a
lot before I get on a plane so I booked
you remember and I'm like dude I was
serious and then after the flight you
gave me my speech I just I did decide
I'll try and think of something so I
thought of something and I gave it to
you at the end of the flight yes but I
haven't I don't remember what it was it
was amazing it was the best speech of
the night it was five words has to be
five words yeah thank you thank you
thank
[Applause]
right everything on the flight I've got
a crack this for Chris let's furry die
I'm glad it worked out worked out and
now you owe me money
you